It's been quite some time since the world
saw a "G.I.
Joe" adventure on the big screen, with the
Dwayne Johnson-led "G.I.
Joe: Retaliation" arriving back in 2013 and
making $375 million worldwide.
The action-thriller wasn't a disappointment,
but it also wasn't a rip-roaring success,
so the future of the Paramount-owned franchise
has been uncertain — although a third film
titled "Ever Vigilant" is supposedly still
in development.
But the series is now pushing forward in a
new direction by fleshing out the origin story
of the team's famed ninja, Snake Eyes, in
his own solo origin film.
With "Crazy Rich Asians" star Henry Golding
leading the film as the titular hero, the
movie sure seemed like an easy win for Paramount
Pictures.
"Snake Eyes" director Robert Shwentke and
screenwriter Evan Spiliotopoulos focus on
intense fight scenes in the film, showing
what could be done with the character in the
right hands.
The first trailer quickly caught the attention
of many action fans, especially since Iko
Uwais — of "The Raid" fame — plays Hard
Master, a key figure in Snake Eyes' backstory.
However, "Snake Eyes" has bombed at the box
office, only pulling in $13 million domestically
alongside a measly $4 million worldwide in
the first three days of its release.
So why the poor debut?
Here's why "Snake Eyes" might have flopped
so badly at the box office.
After plenty of buildup in advance of the
film's release, it seems like the one-two
punch of poor reviews for "Snake Eyes," alongside
growing concerns about the Delta variant of
COVID-19, has put off potential audiences.
Currently, the solo spin-off is sitting at
a 42% rating on Rotten Tomatoes alongside
a B- on CinemaScore.
So as audiences are cautious about returning
to theaters, many fans aren't going to want
to part with their hard-earned cash for a
movie they'll possibly come away from feeling
shortchanged.
"What is it you want?"
"I want it all."
That's basically what Box Office Pro analyst
Shawn Robbins explained to Variety recently,
saying,
"Moviegoing and general household economics
are both still in recovery mode.
Potential audiences are being selective with
what they spend their money on."
It's possible that the film might've had a
better reception if it had debuted as a rental
on a particular streaming service.
But it's also understandable why Paramount
chose to stick with a theatrical release,
since "Snake Eyes" was already delayed four
times throughout the last year thanks to the
ongoing global situation.
There's also the problem of giving a team
player his own adventure in an attempt to
carry a full reboot of the "G.I.
Joe" franchise.
As Franchise Entertainment Research chief
David A. Gross told Variety,
"When a character is spun-off in a thriller
series like this, a big drop follows."
Gross went on to say,
"Demand was simply limited here, especially
without a well-known star or ensemble to drive
interest outside the fan base."
So is franchise fatigue to blame?
It's always difficult to find the next big
franchise that will bring audiences to the
movie theater in droves.
Ever since Marvel Studios seemingly cracked
the code of what a cinematic universe can
do, many studios have tried replicating the
formula with varying degrees of success.
So far, "G.I.
Joe" hasn't really managed to do the same,
even with its lengthy list of characters and
storylines that stretch from the animated
TV shows and movies.
Since there hasn't been a "G.I.
Joe" film since 2013, audiences have had no
real reason to be truly excited about a revival
of the franchise.
Sure, the heavy focus on impressive stunts
and fights was meant to be the hook for "Snake
Eyes,'" but apparently, it isn't enough to
draw moviegoers.
Ultimately, it's possible that the appetite
for new shared universe storytelling is starting
to wane, especially in comparison to properties
like those owned by Marvel and DC.
It's not the first time a studio has failed
to kick-start a new franchise.
In recent years, a good example is the infamous
Dark Universe, which pictured a future where
all of Universal's monster properties would
converge... but then 2017's "The Mummy" did
little to inspire horror fans.
There's also "The Amazing Spider-Man" debacle,
as Sony's attempt at creating its own separate
Marvel universe of Spidey-related characters
faltered following the poor reception to the
sequel.
Perhaps the financial and critical disappointment
of "Snake Eyes" might indicate to Paramount
that it's time to go back to the intellectual
property mine to find something else to adapt
for the big screen.
If you're still curious about the film, "Snake
Eyes" is in theaters now.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.